surtout pas aller si je pense que dans
cet acquis dryats d'hab il ya une part
politiques dont une par les oliviers et
qui est essentielle mais aussi une part
personnelle c'est-à-dire comme disent
les jeunes cazeneuve hollande y sont
vénère l'autre les a roulés dans la
farine
laura donner des leçons et maintenant il
se dit lui renvoie macron les traites de
les renvoie dans l'autre dans le camp
des fainéants et des débats var et donc
moi donc il ya un côté on règle des
comptes parce que on s'est fait trahir
et rouler dans la farine
ça compte aussi en politique donc ça
c'est une première partie des choses et
puis la partie plus politique
je suis d'accord avec olivier quand il
dit que l'euro le retour de françois
hollande est tout à fait improbable sans
doute impossible
ça n'est pas parce que nous nous disons
ça que françois hollande le pense et et
est donc mal j'ai quand même le
sentiment qu aussi curieux que cela
puisse paraître qui se dit que il ya un
espace ça c'est vrai ya un espace entre
macron et mélenchon il n'y a personne
aujourd'hui au parti socialiste en
occuper cet espace et qui va déjà
commencer à l'occuper médiatiquement et
peut-être de mal occupé politiquement
verra